[Musique]
les dates du bol d'or
c'est ainsi que les dates à voir si ça
va mon chéri ça va bien merci et bon
vous savez il ya une brouille qui est en
train de monter le petit à petit mais
personne n'en parle en moi je vais en
parler tout de suite parce que on savait
qu entre jean michel et eric naulleau
c'était autant le grand amour contre
gries vous au public license
une brouille qui prend de plus en plus
en plus dans cette émission ça entre
benjamin castaldi et jean michel mr
non666 pasqua michèle mer ils sont
rouillés que les doses bien les voir
vous allez voir parce qu'après ces
mariages et ses petits humains en
belgique fèves année pour son régime
et ce qui est bizarre c'est que le
patron qui la voient se moquer fait
normal mais les autres pas du tout bon
moi je vous donne des conseils c'est
vrai ou pas je n'ai pas donné des
conseils en loge tout à l'heure c'est
quoi je veux dire on est il faut que
maintenant parce qu'il a pris beaucoup
de muscles franchement il est magnifique
maintenant il faut qu'il sache un peu
donc je dis faut que tu cours voilà à
peu près une heure tous les matins ah
oui quand même
sinon parce que je me dis comme et parce
que sinon il va être c est lui et on
l'est mais lancé en même temps mais
c'est vrai c'est très rageant mais très
élancé du tout il a toujours été très
beau castaldi et je vous lis il va
perdre encore 4,5 kilos mais là il va le
perdre il a séché mais il a eu le gars
gardez le musc et vaccinés jusqu'à deux
heures je pense non non non non mais ne
l'ont par le profit
l'un des suspects n'étaient radio tu as
une chance la physique est bon en tout
cas les images de l'acte ii de cette
brouille qui grandit c'est dans il était
une fois dans tempo j'adore la semaine
dernière souvenez vous quand stomy bugzy
disent avoir perdu du poids pour son
rôle benjamin castaldi est rayé de la
bonne de ses riches son régime
mais pas du tout quand jean-michel
faisait la même veine souvenez vous non
je m'en reste à lille serait pas
crédible à ce titre il faut qu'il fasse
encore deux semaines
comme j'aime avec les hyper v ner contre
jean-michel avant le bouquet final de
cyril et mathieu rappelez vous la
castany la sépaq sommes bien placés
comme j'aime et bien hier soir la même
situation s'est reproduite et c'est
monter encore d'un cran avec jean-michel
tout comme j'aime bien sûr à côté c est
que tu vas pas non mais je sais pas j'ai
une fausse édition c'est plus en plus
bon bah oui ça c'est ma foi mais on peut
être beau et grotesque regardez regardez
raymond et libéraux ont droit aussi
j'ai en moi vraiment mais bon j'aime le
grand
elle regarda benjamin jean michel il a
envie de démonter la race comme quand il
a vu qu'il était remplacé danse et
restauré par christophe beaugrand
le problème c'est comment michel ne se
démonte pas pire encore regardé il le
toise le shérif de la ville va devoir
régler ce problème
boxe castaldi versus calamity mais
regardez
fort des pmp
alors bien sûr il ne faut pas se battre
non non bien sûr mais si la belle
bagarre entre vous deux à est-ce que
vous pensez que vous le défoncer je
défonce bien sûr ils ne sont pas ce
match à sa main
c'est une blague qui des bagarres ce
serait une boucherie démontrer mais le
défaut des genres et c'est un faux dur
il n a aucune chance cinq ans comment
benjamin lévy sur un court il est très
fort en mai sur un coup de fil à une
cuisson s'il est quand même véloce il
est tenace ben salama email c'est quoi
vous après ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
oui moi je dit jean-michel parce qu'il a
mal au genou non mais n'entend pas
normal j'en ai marre je l'aï la peur
emballages où il va se faire opérer
c'est quoi alors vous voyez vous êtes
alors moi je vais vous dire je ne peux
pas je donne mon avis vont mal le pro
les mêmes sont mises d'accord ça fait à
peine ce que je sais que ça va les
toucher si je vous dis qu'un deuil c'est
des fous et des styles bien sûr moi je
vous dis est-ce que vous dis je vous dis
la vérité
battez-vous avec des mots les mots je
vous le dis seront toujours plus forts
que les points acquis ces deux mois ne
savait pas alors que mon ami jimmy
mohamed comme son nom l indique c un
citoyen du monde il a un pied au caire
un pied à new york et le désir à sucy en
brie
alors que là alors tous les noms qui
m'est très belle
[Applaudissements]
alors que non que jimmy maîtrise à la
force ils mélangent alors quand tu dis
avancé à tatillon la place d'avancer à
tâtons si vous ne reprenez pas mais une
fois de plus le visage ne cache rien non
c'est un nouveau zimbabwe ça veut dire
[Rires]
alors c'est vrai que la france a
beaucoup appris avec les pressantes
d'épidémie il faut rappeler aux gens
qu'il ya quatre mois ce camp-là virus on
le connaissait absolument paraît il
était inconnu et donc on apprend tous
les jours
raison pour laquelle parfois on a
l'impression qu'on va d'abord sa tatie
ion
[Musique]
non parce que moi je vous dis tatillon
ça finit là n'arriveront pas de quoi
avez vous joué un comptoir et espère lui
il veut ainsi pousser à châtillon où
c'est à tatum est attaquée aux genevois
la messe à tâtons pas dans l'hacienda
tillon c'est autre chose alors fait ils
ont défoncé
cette année on assiste à une
métamorphose en a découvert un nouveau
gilbert days c'est une thalasso le mec
que c'est fou j'ai l'impression que
c'est une pierre chaude mais ça nous en
ferons mais c'est fois on me demande
souvent pourquoi il devenu si calme à
l'explication est simple tu passes six
mois dans ces que de la télé je peux
dire ça traumatise invités j'ai comme la
prison
[Rires]
il est
ces prix trois mois ci
ils m'ont dit là je récidive encore une
fois si tu peux joey starr c'était fun
j'ai commencé la bataille alors j'ai
commencé j'étais très bien alors fini
les coups de gueule de gilles mal à m'en
vouloir tirer des coups de gueule de
gilles carle d'invités place au gym tout
doux qui a des compléments de fou à tout
ce qu'on reçoit rêverie l'égide c'est
devenu le nouveau zizou et mini
[Musique]
g
catastrophe est une honte pour moi c'est
les calamités doublé mais il est mal à
l'aise
il est froid il entraîne automatiquement
on dirait un mauvais débutants
inadmissible qu'on vire et en plus je
veux dire j'aime pas les invités
continuent ils savaient que nourrir à
chanter darkness
[Musique]
magix val d'oise
première fois retenu jusque là tu n'es
qu'un hypocrite go way et les caniveaux
c'est parce que tu taille de leurs mots
tu as raison c'est un gros con c'était
une gigue d'avant aujourd'hui c'est pas
ce qui lui arrive et fait des
compléments de sous à tous les invités
j'étais malade et fatigué je suis sorti
guéri l'euphorique votre duo est
formidable a eu lieu à des scènes
d'anthologie les dialogues sont
formidables histoires aussi la scène et
forme il faut y aller de toute urgence
avant j aime un sens particulier
d'hospitalité et aujourd'hui n'arrive
pas s'empêcher de clamer son amour pour
les invités qui seront faits un bijou à
voir en famille est très branché mine de
rien ce qui est fou c'est le côté
artiste complet quoi vous ne chantez
vous êtes acteur vous savez donc de
faire avec bonheur avec talent et vous
le remplissez d'allégresse bâtir un truc
mina limogeage
voir michael que j'embrasse forme on
cherche pour finir pour finir je voulais
revenir sur jeudi dernier parce que
balances ton post est magnifique c'était
magnifique parce qu'en fait je prends
des fiches si vous voulez c'était la
dernière fois c'est la première fois que
jean mais s'il n'était pas là j'ai
remarqué dont il s'était son
anniversaire dans un bar à chicha avec
marine le pen mais y avait son
remplaçant officiel nicolas dupont
aignan est une fois de plus hier vous
avez prouvé que vous étiez le digne
héritier de michel drucker dans la
manière de converser votre invité voici
vivement jeudi l'émission qui est
communément dimanche sauf que ceux qui
rouge et karl hotz est pas le canapé
c'est les fesses de nicolas dupont
aignan de regarder ceux ci fais pas ça
s'est passé
évidemment c'est pas demain vous voilà
c'est ça mais remets tes leçons
[Musique]
dès la première intervention de
l'inviter cyril hanouna cela je dirais
que décolla du point nous voulons avoir
peur mais le rôle d'un gouvernement
c'est quoi si vous êtes venus ici
pourquoi j'avais 2022 c'est pas la peine
avais je voulais je m'en [ __ ] dans la
région dont la première à chaud je vous
pose une question doit-on avoir peur et
on partait sur des trucs complètement
hors sujet c'est un support sujet by
fred-mars et à l'époque et les
politesses je parle maintenant comment
aussi à l'époque ne vous va faire la
gauche aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
quand même des mesures et que sûr mais
c'est facile de se moquer nicolas dupont
aignan je vous le rouge et il me déçoit
là on est parti sur des confédérations
on est sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
allaient vous parlez pas de concret
cyril et n'en suis pas là pour gagner on
vire les en fait c'est toujours celui
qui parlent le plus qui se plaint tout
le temps de neuvième avant la parole et
le pauvre nicolas dupont aignan il va
donc décidé de mettre le holà avec
beaucoup d'autorité voire à les
féliciter
il ya maintenant ça suffit on verra
plein
célèbre au jo
non
complicité qui haussent évidente que
celle entre booba et carris
la russie tout en étant l'urgence est là
vous nous parler de n'importe quoi mais
ça qu'on apprend est-ce que j'ai peur
des moyens vous venez libramont les
malades traités est ce que vous faites
c'est contre-productif suis désolé mais
bon jeu de cette arrestation est la
différence entre une expertise de la
poste au nom
ça s'est très bien passé après
franchement et je l'espère parce
qu'après il chante et danse on aimerait
bien sûr on est d'accord sur rien ces
voix là mais on est il des sports moi ça
m'arrange tyrolienne genre myriam
magnifique bras bon j'aimerais y aller
cuir du frontman du rappel
[Applaudissements]